l'alcool ne détruit pas que ta vie ben
si lui
ces projets obligé d'en faire le deuil
depuis que tu l'a clouée dans un
fauteuil à cause de cette soirée
alcoolisée ou tu t'es pris points 1,01
euro qui n'a pas vu venir le verbe de
trop c'est une scène du quotidien
une soirée alcoolisée un chauffeur qui
prend le volant on n'a pas le droit de
prendre le volant en étant alcoolisées
parce que c'est prendre un danger pour
soi c'est prendre un danger pour la vie
des autres et ça on n'a pas le droit
écueil et elle elle tu l'a fauché en
plein vol
quand tu tes couilles capable de
conduire sous alcool alcool détruit pas
que ta vie
[Musique]
un col ne détruit pas que ta vie mais
celle de tes proches de ses victimes et
leurs proches de 6 ben si c'est vraiment
tout l'intérêt de ce petit film rose de
montrer que prendre le volant sous
l'emprise de l'alcool n'applique pas que
sa propre vie
ça implique on met en danger autrui sans
en avoir forcément conscience
en face il ya quelqu'un qui peut perdre
la vie il ya quelqu'un qui peut être
paralysé les personnes sont impactés
mais y'a pas que la personne qui est
impactée il ya toute la famille aussi en
diffusant le court métrage en avant
première de tous les films au cinéma
l'union des médecins notamment toucher
la jeunesse choqué pendant la période de
fêtes où un sentiment de liberté fait
perdre le sens des réalités
pour vous ce sont des images de fiction
où vous comprenez que c'est aussi la
réalité mais on comprend que c'est la
réalité ça me fait réfléchir sur l on a
vraiment besoin de l'alcool pour
s'amuser dans les soirées ça vous arrive
de dire non lorsque vous êtes conduite
par quelqu'un qui a bu mon ordination
cogeca et puis je dis non et même je lui
dois prendre le volant
voilà un peu choquant
ce que vous avez peur vous parfois
lorsque vous prenez la route sont toutes
en jupes or tout le temps avec vos
conneries tout ça pour ça tu es dans
votre entourage on fait attention ou pas
toujours facile quand il y en a qui font
vraiment pas la tension qui ne
ne prennent pas de réflexion et qui
prennent le volant même s'ils ont bu et
voilà avec l'alcool ils ont pas la même
attention sur la route
donc n'importe quoi peut arriver sans le
vouloir j'ai beaucoup persiste ce
sentiment d'invulnérabilité la croyance
que certains saurait tenir l'alcool une
illusion
chez chacun l'alcool alter fortement le
champ de vision
le temps de réflexes et la perception de
ses capacités